Jonathan Frakes has said that the
success of strange new worlds has been a
little bit Bittersweet cross your leg
over the back of it and slam down
command that
chair why welcome to sidere your Sci-Fi
TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel don't shred rker my good Fortune
is your good
[Music]
fortune I don't need your fantasy women
in Discovery we got that Series where
Pike was the captain we saw the
Enterprise briefly we saw Spock we saw
number one and when that series ended
the fans went
berserk they screamed at the top of
their lungs give us a series of that we
want to see Anson mount's Pike an awful
lot more we love how you've cast a lot
of these characters give us a full-blown
series and then when they
did pretty much everyone loved it the
fans and the critics alike Jonathan
Frakes was recently talking about this
in an interview and he said that was
great it was brilliant to see Star Trek
being appreciated for the show that it
was but
a lot of people started saying this is
the Star Trek we've been waiting for
this is the Star Trek we want not
Discovery and not at that point the
first two seasons of
peard and Jonathan Franks cannot help
but feel that that is a little bit
cutting especially considering how much
he was involved in both of those
projects the reason why I'm doing a
video on this though is I am so grateful
to see somebody really high up
acknowledge the fact that strange new
worlds and then peard season three to be
fair is more like Star Trek than what
came just before it Discovery and the
first two seasons of peard is not what a
lot of trekkies wanted to see we don't
really understand it as Star Trek we
don't identify it as Star Trek
particularly the first season the
discovery however beautifully it was
made stuck in the throat of a lot of
trekkies because of things like the way
the Klingons were the way the Kling gons
looked a way a lot of the way the ships
were and the way oh God the way star
Fleet behaved and changes to Cannon etc
etc and if you like the new track or you
don't like it you have to appreciate and
have to acknowledge really that it's
been divisive it has really divided
trekkies some do adore it and all good
for you some adored Strange New World's
musical episode some hated it whichever
side of that argument you appear on it's
divisive and Jonathan fraks is really I
think Brave and honest to acknowledge it
some hardcore trackies that are on the
pro new trk side don't want to
acknowledge this at all they don't want
to admit that some people and some
hardcore trekky fans don't like the new
series and they don't want to
acknowledge why a lot of fans will say h
Canon it doesn't matter it's a TV show
and strange new worlds for example is a
new TV show so yes of course they can
change things whereas other fans think
that's sacrilege that actually think
changing Cannon really takes the mick
out of everything that came before what
is the point of having a show within a
franchise within a universe if you don't
respect what came before for me I'm a
little bit in between I think Canon
should be respected but I do think that
if the story demands something that
Canon can be fudged there are certain
rules that can be bent there are certain
rules that can be broken and there are
certain rules that can't there are
certain things if something historically
referenced that should not be changed
for example Spock hasn't got a sister
there was no need to do that and Spock
EV and sister is a good example because
there was no reason to do that there
could have been lots of reasons why
Michael Burham felt strongly about Spock
they trained together or something else
something that was logical and makes
sense would have been better now don't
get me wrong the way they did it because
Spock's dad had lots and lots of wives
couple of humor wives over the way
having a half sister all right fine but
the fact that it was never mentioned
that's something that would have been
mentioned at some point is a problem and
annoying a lot of fans really have
warmed to Strange New worlds mostly not
the musical but have swarmed to Strange
New worlds a lot of fans are desperate
for legacy Following season 3 of
Bard we love these shows so much and we
are so desperate for legacy because we
can see that it's Star Trek again we can
see that it's not Alex curtzman JJ
Abrams version of Star Trek it's Star
Trek and for me I can understand why
Jonathan fraks because he was involved
in lots of those projects he's directed
Discovery episodes Etc I can see why it
would cause a bit of sweetness for him
but more importantly I can really
respect that he has been brave enough to
say out loud something that a lot of us
trekkies have been screaming for a
while and hopefully the reset that we've
been seeing over the last couple of
years of Star Trek can continue and
where Trek is going over the next few
years is going to be a place where all
of us trekkies can feel we actually
recognize it
as Star
Trek old and new fans alike they will
continue to make TV shows for different
demographics a younger audience an older
audience a in between
audience but to be honest if they just
focused on making good Star Trek good TV
shows with a interesting cast they would
make us all happy just like strange new
worlds has mostly not the musical
but guys get into the comments and tell
me what you think do you think Jonathan
Frank's words are brave or just think
he's being honest and actually this is
obvious what a trek is that can't see
this thinking or actually do you think
no Jonathan fraks his way off here all
right new Tre was different but it's
still good and you know okay maybe
there's been a bit of an evolution of
the secret hideout version of Star Trek
but it's all been logical and made sense
and you know
maybe you don't see what people are
complaining about I'd love to know
exactly what you think get to the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also go to patreon.com citre where most
of our new videos Premier first and you
get to see them without the adverts also
you can go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on many of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more information for you to digest
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next
[Music]
time